I was very happy to be in Birmingham but
I did want to go somewhere a little bit
more exotic working with Stephen I never
get tired of the experience of seeing
him walking onto set and getting that
little frisson of life always comes
team's bill Veck
you obviously teach yourself to be a
little bit more calm and reserved in his
presence but it's still a novelty to me
and I've worked with them three times
now but I still get very excited when he
appears just because it's him working
with Steven Spielberg you know it's i
working with Steven Spielberg small
indie film director he's a giant that
doesn't make you feel small he undercuts
your nervousness with his own neuroses
and nervousness and he's incredibly kind
and generous and also a genius at the
same time we had two weeks of rehearsal
on our own on the last day of our
rehearsals Steven actually showed up he
said I just want to capture you walking
I wanted you to do like the John
Travolta walk from the beginning of
Saturday Night Fever I'm standing there
on the motion-capture floor and it's
just me on one side and him on the other
and I'm waiting for him to call action
and but he's not saying anything and
then he pulls out his phone and then he
hits play and he starts playing staying
alive by the Bee Gees and he starts
walking towards me and he's playing this
song for like 15 seconds nodding his
head and then he goes and action and
then that was that was like my first
experience working with with Steven I
got calls saying I'm gonna be in a
Steven Spielberg movie I'm thinking
Hawaii I'm thinking
like Japan I'm thinking somewhere really
crazy and being from old in in Greater
Manchester I didn't think that would be
film in part of the film in Birmingham I
was very happy to be in Birmingham but I
did want to go somewhere a little bit
more exotic no I never went to
Birmingham oh yeah I was only ever in
Watford for this film which is a
glamorous location I can assure you we
had it a trailer actually our base camp
because it had tons of arcade games and
we had an Xbox and we would play fifa
every day at lunch yes I've played
computer games since before any of you
little Punk's out there I go back to the
arcades your little console freaks I go
back to pinball pinball Bar None I don't
know what's gonna happen I'm positive
that this current climate is just a blip
on the way to progression I think the
world that this film portrays is very
similar to what I think will actually be
the case it's slightly daunting and and
doomy but at the same time you'll be
able to ride on a dinosaur so it swings
and roundabouts Stephen because he's
just secured well infinite knowledge and
you can ask him anything and he'll
remember it'll give you the day the time
the person and it's from like a really
obscure it so I'm at the nineteen forty
isn't yet how do you remember that
probably me I would imagine I I don't
know I tie it it was so funny working
with him because Stephen and myself were
sort of trying to educate him on sort of
films that he hadn't seen like there
were certain films he hadn't seen which
you assume everyone's seen there were
moments of like oh my god you've not
seen this you should come to my house
and watches immediately